New from Nespresso. Blend wellness into your coffee routine with a coffee plus range, infused with functional benefits. Choose the coffee you love with added B vitamins, like coffee plus B12 to help support immune function, and coffee plus B6 to keep your day moving. Or go with the flow and choose ginseng delight. Our new double espresso with ginseng extract. Whatever lies ahead, don't change your morning. Let your morning change you.
Nespresso 新品上市。将健康融入您的咖啡日常，推出具有功能性益处的咖啡系列。选择您喜爱的咖啡，添加维生素B，例如咖啡加B12有助于支持免疫功能，咖啡加B6让您的一天充满活力。或者随心选择人参咖啡。我们全新的双份浓缩咖啡，添加了人参提取物。无论前方有什么，都不要改变您的早晨。让您的早晨改变您。
Discover coffee plus on nispresso.com. Envy is a much maligned emotion. Our feelings about it are evident even in the language we use to describe it. We say people are twisted or consumed by or eaten up with envy. In folk tales, books and movies, envy is a villain. In the Christian tradition, envy is one of the seven deadly sins. But in recent years, some psychologists and philosophers have begun taking a second look at this long, vilified emotion
在nespresso.com探索咖啡加系列。嫉妒是一种被严重误解的情绪。我们对它的感受甚至体现在我们描述它的语言中。我们说人们被嫉妒扭曲、吞噬或蚕食。在民间故事、书籍和电影中，嫉妒是反派。在基督教传统中，嫉妒是七宗罪之一。但近年来，一些心理学家和哲学家开始重新审视这种长期被妖魔化的情绪，
and making the case that envy is not always destructive. In some cases, it can even be a force for good. So what exactly is envy and how has it gotten such a bad rap? Why are we often envious of people closest to us and how does envy affect our relationships? How can we learn to use envy in more constructive ways? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
并提出嫉妒并不总是具有破坏性的观点。在某些情况下，它甚至可以成为一种向善的力量。那么，嫉妒到底是什么？它为何名声如此糟糕？为什么我们经常嫉妒最亲近的人？嫉妒如何影响我们的人际关系？我们如何学会以更具建设性的方式利用嫉妒？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
I have two guests today, a psychologist and a philosopher who both study envy. First is Dr. Jens Lange, a professor of psychology at the Health and Medical University in Airford, Germany. His research focuses on measuring emotions, especially envy and pride, and understanding the role they play in interpersonal behavior. He is the author of dozens of journal articles on topics including how envy shapes social hierarchies, how personality traits, such as narcissism linked to envy, and the difference between benign and malicious envy. My next guest is Dr. Sarah Protassi. Dr. Pratasi is a professor of philosophy at the University of Puget Sound in Tacoma, Washington,
今天我有两位嘉宾，一位心理学家和一位哲学家，他们都研究嫉妒。首先是延斯·兰格博士，德国埃尔福特健康与医学大学的心理学教授。他的研究重点是衡量情绪，特别是嫉妒和自豪感，并理解它们在人际行为中扮演的角色。他撰写了数十篇期刊文章，主题包括嫉妒如何塑造社会等级，人格特质（如自恋）如何与嫉妒相关联，以及良性嫉妒与恶意嫉妒之间的区别。我的下一位嘉宾是萨拉·普罗塔西博士。普罗塔西博士是华盛顿州塔科马市普吉特湾大学的哲学教授，
where she studies moral psychology and the philosophy of emotions. She is author of the books The Philosophy of Envy and the Moral Psychology of Envy, and she has discussed the value of envy with media outlets, including the Wall Street Journal, the Globe and Mail, and ABC Radio, Australia. Dr. Longa, Dr. Protasi, thank you both for joining me. Thank you so much for having us, Kim. Let me start by asking how you define envy in your work, and what's the difference between jealousy and envy,
她在那里研究道德心理学和情绪哲学。她是《嫉妒的哲学》和《嫉妒的道德心理学》等书的作者，并曾与《华尔街日报》、《环球邮报》和澳大利亚ABC广播电台等媒体讨论过嫉妒的价值。兰格博士，普罗塔西博士，非常感谢你们两位的到来。非常感谢邀请我们，金。让我先问一下，你们在工作中是如何定义嫉妒的，以及嫉妒和羡慕有什么区别，
because people often use those terms interchangeably, and they're not really the same. Dr. Longa, why don't you take that one? So envy is initially a painful feeling, resulting from an unfettering comparison with another person, And so this higher-ranked person is superior in a domain of high personal relevance to the lower-ranked person. So I am, for instance, or I can be envious of Sarah's amazing book on envy, right, because I am a scientist. This is personally relevant, but I wouldn't be envious of Leonardo DiCaprio's acting skills because I'm not an actor.
因为人们经常混用这两个词，但它们其实并不相同。兰格博士，您来回答这个问题好吗？嫉妒最初是一种痛苦的感觉，源于与他人的不平等比较。这种排名较高的人在对排名较低者具有高度个人相关性的领域中表现优越。例如，我可以嫉妒萨拉那本关于嫉妒的精彩著作，因为我是一名科学家。这与我个人相关，但我不会嫉妒莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥的演技，因为我不是演员。
So envy occurs when someone else has something that a person desires. And in contrast, jealousy occurs when a person is afraid of losing something that they already have, so typically a romantic partner. Dr. Potasi, you've written about four different types of envy. What are they and what do they tell us about the different ways that envy can show up in our lives? So it's funny because I was also planning to use my envy for Jens as an example. And so he stole my idea and now I'm very envious of that. So let's take the example of, you know, professional envy, right? And as, as Yens, you know, beautifully explained, envy is this unpleasant,
所以，当别人拥有某人渴望的东西时，嫉妒就会产生。相比之下，羡慕（jealousy）发生在一个人害怕失去已经拥有的东西时，通常指浪漫伴侣。普罗塔西博士，您写过四种不同类型的嫉妒。它们是什么？它们告诉我们嫉妒在生活中以何种方式表现出来？这很有趣，因为我也打算用我嫉妒延斯作为例子。他偷了我的想法，现在我非常嫉妒这一点。让我们以职业嫉妒为例。正如延斯精彩解释的那样，嫉妒是一种令人不快的、
aversive response to some kind of perceived inferiority or disadvantage vis-à-vis a similar other. So Yens and I are roughly, you know, the same age, the same occupation. And so he's, even though, you know, he's a man and a woman, there's going to be some other differences. But I can perceive him as similar to me. and I can envy him with regard to a good that is relevant to my sense of identity and such as, for instance, academic success, right?
对某种感知到的劣势或相对于相似他人的劣势的厌恶反应。延斯和我的年龄、职业大致相同。所以，尽管他是男性，我是女性，会有其他差异，但我可以感知到他与我相似。并且我可以在与我身份认同相关的领域嫉妒他，例如学术成就。
So I envy the fact that he is a renowned expert on envy and he's all this public. He has many more publications than me. I may have a book, but he has many, many publications, right? But now there are some other conditions that, so this is kind of the background that just envy in general situation, right? But then in my work, I present a model that is not meant to be cross-cultural. It's meant to characterize the kinds of envy that contemporary people in Western society is my, like Yance and I, my experience.
所以我嫉妒他是著名的嫉妒专家，而且他如此出名。他比我有更多的出版物。我可能有一本书，但他有非常非常多的出版物。但现在还有其他条件，这只是嫉妒的一般背景。但在我的工作中，我提出了一个模型，它并非旨在跨文化，而是旨在描述当代西方社会的人（像延斯和我）的体验。
Now, imagine that I am really concerned with being a good researcher, right? I mean, that's something that is at the core of my identity. I really care about that. And I envy Yen's, but what I'm mostly concerned is, okay, I am not as good as Yance, and his academic excellence exacerbates my pain. But it's not the main focus of concern for me. It's just that the fact that he's similar to me is sort of, as Aristotle would say, it's a reproach to me, why I haven't been able to be as productive,
现在，想象我非常关心成为一名优秀的研究员，这是我身份的核心。我真的很在乎这一点。我嫉妒延斯，但我最关心的是，我不如延斯优秀，他的学术卓越加剧了我的痛苦。但这并不是我关注的重点。只是他与我相似的事实，正如亚里士多德所说，是对我的一种责备，为什么我没能像他那样多产，
but mostly what I care about is becoming better as a researcher. And let's suppose that I'm a fairly self-confident person, and then thanks to Yen's generosity in, you know, he has maybe shown, me how to be a successful researcher, I feel confident that I can improve my situation, that I can emulate Yens and become a better researcher myself. And so I feel what I call emulative envy, which is still painful, right, because it's still a perception of my inferiority compared to this other person, but there is hope. It's a productive emotion that motivates me to self-improve. Now, let's change the example a little bit. Imagine that I'm actually
但我最关心的是作为一名研究员变得更好。假设我是一个相当自信的人，多亏了延斯的慷慨，他可能向我展示了如何成为一名成功的研究员，我觉得我有信心改善自己的处境，我可以效仿延斯，自己成为一名更好的研究员。所以我感受到了我所说的“效仿型嫉妒”，它仍然是痛苦的，因为这仍然是对我与他人相比处于劣势的感知，但其中有希望。这是一种激励我自我提升的生产性情绪。现在，让我们稍微改变一下例子。想象我实际上
fairly insecure or perhaps I'm in a difficult work situation. I have a lot of teaching on my institution and I start fretting and I'm like, oh no, my God, I will never be able to be as good as Yens as a researcher. And so even though it's not like I'm hostile to Yens, I feel, I start feeling like, yeah, maybe I shouldn't talk to him as much, otherwise I feel bad about myself. I start withdrawing from the relationship, I start sulking a little bit. And I feel this kind of self-defeating emotion where I, I want to have something that I perceive as unattainable. And this is what I call, this is the unproductive version of emulative envy, and I've called it inert envy. And I think this, for instance, applies well to cases of, like, baby envy, where there is someone who wants to have a biological
相当不自信，或者可能我处于一个困难的工作环境中。我在机构里有很多教学任务，我开始焦虑，心想，天哪，我永远无法像延斯那样成为一名优秀的研究员。所以，虽然我并不敌视延斯，但我开始觉得，也许我不应该和他多说话，否则我会对自己感觉不好。我开始疏远这段关系，开始有点闷闷不乐。我感受到了这种自我挫败的情绪，我想要得到我感知为无法获得的东西。这就是我所说的“效仿型嫉妒”的非生产性版本，我称之为“惰性嫉妒”。我认为这适用于例如“婴儿嫉妒”的情况，有人想要一个亲生的
child. And that's really tough sometimes, right? Sometimes it's just a matter of, like, what your body can and cannot do. And it's not like you want other people to lose their children, God forbid, right? But maybe you stop hanging out with your friends with children, because it's a little too painful. Now, imagine instead that, you know, maybe I've known Yenz for a long time, maybe we're childhood friends, and I've always kind of, he was always so successful when I wasn't. That's kind of irritating. Why is Yen's always good at everything, right? And so for whatever reason I developed this rivalry with this person. And so, it's not like I necessarily care about the good that I feel I lack. It's just that there is this background of rivalry. And so I, I, and so I, I, and I don't,
孩子。这有时真的很艰难。有时这只是你的身体能做什么和不能做什么的问题。并不是说你希望别人失去他们的孩子，天哪，当然不是。但也许你不再和有孩子的朋友出去玩了，因为这太痛苦了。现在，想象一下，也许我认识延斯很久了，也许我们是童年好友，他总是那么成功，而我却不是。这有点令人恼火。为什么延斯总是擅长一切？所以无论出于什么原因，我与这个人产生了竞争。所以，我并不一定关心我感到缺乏的那种好处。只是存在这种竞争背景。所以，我，我，我，我没有，
I'm motivated to kind of pull him down, right? I want him to do less well rather than improve myself. And so maybe I will engage in these malicious behaviors that are often so salient in envy, our discussions of envy. I want to sabotage him in some way. And then I have two options, right? Maybe I feel confident that I can pull him down. Maybe I can metaphorically steal the good or really still the good. And I can sabotage it and maybe, you know, I get to, you know, take his place in a,
我有动力去打压他。我希望他表现得没那么好，而不是提升我自己。所以也许我会参与那些在嫉妒讨论中经常出现的恶意行为。我想以某种方式破坏他。然后我有两个选择。也许我觉得我有信心能打压他。也许我可以隐喻地窃取这种好处，或者真的窃取这种好处。我可以破坏它，也许我能取代他在，
in a grant application somehow, but not because I've become a better researcher, right? I've operated in mischievous ways. And so I can steal the good. And that's what I call aggressive envy. Or finally, maybe I can spread rumors about something about Yen's behavior. And so people don't invite him to conferences or don't invite him to participate in symposal and all of that. But I haven't improved my situation.
在某种资助申请中的位置，但不是因为我成为了更好的研究员。我以恶作剧的方式行事。所以我可以窃取这种好处。这就是我所说的“攻击型嫉妒”。或者最后，也许我可以散布关于延斯行为的谣言。这样人们就不会邀请他参加会议，或者不邀请他参加研讨会等等。但我并没有改善我的处境。
I've just spoiled the good. I've just spoiled his success without thereby getting anything in exchange. call that spiteful envy. And that, again, might be because I don't feel confident in, like, you know, taking away the good from him, or maybe the situation is such that it doesn't allow it. So those are the four kinds of envy, emulative, inert, aggressive, and spiteful. And in the book, I talk more about, you know, the moral implications and also why I think this model might be helpful to think about our envy, so that we can move from the worst kinds of envy to the better kinds of envy. Dr. Longa, I want to ask you if psychological research draws similar distinctions among the different types of envy.
我只是破坏了这种好处。我只是破坏了他的成功，而没有从中得到任何东西。我称之为“怨恨型嫉妒”。这可能又是因为我不觉得有信心从他那里夺走这种好处，或者情况不允许。这就是四种嫉妒：效仿型、惰性型、攻击型和怨恨型。在书中，我谈到了更多关于道德含义的内容，以及为什么我认为这个模型有助于思考我们的嫉妒，以便我们可以从最坏的嫉妒转向更好的嫉妒。兰格博士，我想问您心理学研究是否在不同类型的嫉妒之间做出了类似的区分。
Yeah, I think they are similar, right, but not identical. So in psychology in general and also for envy, people typically take a so-called social functional approach. So the idea being that emotions also envy help people dealing with certain social situations, typically social problems or challenges. For envy, the problem is that someone is better of, right, or that the self is worse of, in a domain of high personal relevance. So people want to deal with this situation. And they can do this by improving themselves, right?
是的，我认为它们很相似，但不完全相同。在心理学中，通常也包括嫉妒，人们通常采取所谓的社会功能方法。其理念是，情绪（包括嫉妒）帮助人们处理特定的社会情况，通常是社会问题或挑战。对于嫉妒，问题在于别人过得更好，或者自己在高度个人相关的领域中处于劣势。所以人们想要处理这种情况。他们可以通过提升自己来做到这一点，
Then problem solved. This is what psychologists often call benign envy. Or they can try to pull the other person down, so harm the other person's position, which also level the difference. And this is typically called malicious envy. And this maps onto the types that Sarah mentioned. So she herself wrote in one of her papers that benign envy very close to eminative envy or malicious envy is very close to aggressive envy. And that is benign malicious distinction kind of misses especially in non-envy.
然后问题就解决了。这就是心理学家常说的“良性嫉妒”。或者他们可以尝试打压对方，损害对方的地位，这也拉平了差距。这通常被称为“恶意嫉妒”。这与萨拉提到的类型相对应。她在自己的一篇论文中写道，良性嫉妒非常接近效仿型嫉妒，而恶意嫉妒非常接近攻击型嫉妒。这种良性与恶意的区分在非嫉妒领域可能有所缺失。
In general, like my personal opinion is that envy is like doesn't occur in different types or in different categories. So in my opinion, emotions and also envy. kind of processes that unfold in particular social situation. So in the case of envy, people encounter a higher-ranked person. They experience pain because not having this is relevant to them. And then they want to deal with the situation. And depending on how they evaluate it, then this may become benign or malicious envy or may lead to self-improvement or harming.
总的来说，我的个人观点是，嫉妒并不以不同的类型或类别出现。在我看来，情绪（包括嫉妒）是在特定社会情境中展开的过程。在嫉妒的情况下，人们遇到排名更高的人。他们感到痛苦，因为没有这些东西与他们相关。然后他们想要处理这种情况。根据他们如何评估它，这可能会变成良性或恶意嫉妒，或者可能导致自我提升或伤害。
So, for instance, evidence indicates that when people consider the other person's advantage to be undeserved, then. and the situation is more likely to unfold towards harming behavior, so malicious envy. And when people consider likely that they will obtain the envy good themselves, then the situation is more likely to unfold towards self-improvement. So benign envy. So I find these types to be interesting and inspiring, right?
例如，证据表明，当人们认为对方的优势是不应得的时候，情况就更有可能向伤害行为发展，即恶意嫉妒。而当人们认为自己很有可能获得嫉妒的好处时，情况就更有可能向自我提升发展，即良性嫉妒。所以我发现这些类型很有趣且富有启发性，
And if it would occur in data, then that would also be perfectly fine. So in our research, we took a purely empirical approach, So we asked people to rate whether certain elements of this envy process applied to situations in which they experience envy. So for instance, how much did you actually desire the envy object? How much did you feel inferior and so on? And then we used analytic techniques that helped you to identify higher order factors. So things that group certain elements of this envy process together. and we find evidence for these painful feelings,
如果它们出现在数据中，那也完全没问题。在我们的研究中，我们采取了纯粹的实证方法。我们要求人们评价嫉妒过程的某些要素是否适用于他们经历嫉妒的情况。例如，你实际上有多渴望嫉妒的对象？你感到多自卑等等。然后我们使用了有助于识别高阶因素的分析技术。即那些将嫉妒过程的某些要素组合在一起的东西。我们发现了这些痛苦感受的证据，
for what psychologists like to call benign envy, and for what psychologists like to call malicious envy. And we didn't find any other factors. So just based on an empirical level, I think we cannot find these four different types, but we have a very similar distinction. So I don't think that this leads to a deep disagreement between the two of us, right? But we don't find these four types in the data, and I also prefer not calling them types.
对于心理学家喜欢称之为良性嫉妒的东西，以及心理学家喜欢称之为恶意嫉妒的东西。我们没有发现任何其他因素。所以仅从实证层面来看，我认为我们无法找到这四种不同的类型，但我们有一个非常相似的区分。所以我不认为这导致了我们两人之间的深刻分歧。但我们在数据中没有发现这四种类型，而且我也不倾向于称它们为类型。
In your research, do you find that everybody admits to feeling envy at some point, or are there people who never feel envy? I think that people often say they don't experience envy, but in my opinion, the truth is everyone does. If you ask someone like, are you envious or do you ever experience envy, then they often say, no, I never did because it's a sin, as we said. But then if you ask them, for instance, have you ever compared to someone else in a domain of high personal relevance to you, right? let's say in your job, for instance, and then you were either motivated or you gossiped about the other person. So I say, yeah, obviously this just happened to me yesterday, right? So I think if you describe it by not using the word NB, given that it is so, you know, considered
在您的研究中，您是否发现每个人都会承认在某个时刻感到嫉妒，还是有些人从不感到嫉妒？我认为人们经常说他们没有经历过嫉妒，但在我看来，事实是每个人都会。如果你问某人，你嫉妒吗，或者你是否经历过嫉妒，他们通常会说，不，我从来没有，因为正如我们所说，这是一种罪。但如果你问他们，例如，你是否曾经在对你高度个人相关的领域与他人进行过比较，比如在你的工作中，然后你要么受到激励，要么在背后议论对方。那么他们会说，是的，显然这昨天刚发生在我身上。所以我认为，如果你在描述它时不使用“嫉妒”这个词，考虑到它被认为像你在介绍中所说的那样邪恶，人们永远不会同意。但基本过程，我称之为嫉妒过程，这是人们经常经历的。
to be as evil as you said in your introduction, and then people never agree to it, but the basic process, what I would call the envy process, this is what people have frequently experienced. I do like to think that my taxonomy has at least some empirical support, partly because I also use a lot of your work to argue for it. But maybe the details of that are appropriate to another place and time. But in my experience, I have to say that when I talk about once people are familiar with the way I and other people think about ambias, not necessarily this terrible sin or this dysfunctional emotion, they tend to. to be more willing to discuss their envy and admit it. I find that a lot more people now confess their envy to me in those terms precisely because they know that I don't think envy is all bad. So I do think that the framing is really important more so than the words we use. Yeah, true. Does envy only
我确实认为我的分类法至少有一些实证支持，部分原因是我也利用了你们的大量工作来论证它。但也许细节在其他地方和时间讨论更合适。但在我的经验中，我必须说，当我谈论一旦人们熟悉了我和其他人思考嫉妒的方式，即它不一定是一种可怕的罪恶或功能失调的情绪时，他们往往更愿意讨论他们的嫉妒并承认它。我发现现在有更多人以这些术语向我坦白他们的嫉妒，正是因为他们知道我不认为嫉妒全是坏事。所以我确实认为框架比我们使用的词汇更重要。是的，确实。嫉妒是否只
apply to people or could I envy a thing like your beautiful car or your expensive house? I like to think about this as a tripartite relation where you, the age and the person who's feeling the emotion, envy is directed at a person because of some kind of object where that object that is perceived as one perceives as lacking. And the object can be a physical object, a material object, or it can be a property of a person or it can be something more abstract, right? But in the logical sense, there's always three things. The envier, the envied, and the object, the good something that is perceived as good that I don't have and the other person has, I would say. I agree, yeah. And I think it would be strange to say that you are envying the car because of the
适用于人，或者我可以嫉妒像你漂亮的汽车或昂贵的房子这样的东西吗？我喜欢把它看作一种三方关系，你，作为代理人和感受情绪的人，嫉妒指向一个人，因为某种对象，即感知为缺乏的对象。这个对象可以是物理对象、物质对象，也可以是人的属性，或者更抽象的东西。但在逻辑意义上，总是有三件事。嫉妒者、被嫉妒者和对象，即那种被感知为好但我不拥有而对方拥有的东西。我同意。而且如果说你因为汽车的，我不知道，漂亮的转向盘而嫉妒汽车，那会很奇怪。
cars, I don't know, nice steering wheel. Well, let me change the subject a little bit. The two of you wrote a paper together called an interdisciplinary perspective on the value of envy. What inspired you to take this look at the topic and what can we learn from approaching it from both your perspectives. Yeah, so Yitz and I met in 2019 at a conference organized by Thimo Breyer, who had this wonderful idea of this conference that was titled Hostile Emotions, Perspectives from Philosophy and Psychology. And he invited, he thought about a set of emotions, it was discussed, contempt, envy, antipathy, resentiment, and maybe a couple of others. And for each session, he invited a philosopher and a psychologist to talk about it. And so that's where Yance and I met. And it was,
好吧，让我稍微换个话题。你们两人合写了一篇名为《关于嫉妒价值的跨学科视角》的论文。是什么启发你们从这个角度审视这个话题，从你们两人的视角出发，我们能学到什么？是的，延斯和我在2019年的一次会议上相遇，该会议由蒂莫·布雷尔组织，他有一个关于这次会议的绝妙想法，标题为《敌对情绪：哲学与心理学的视角》。他邀请了，他考虑了一系列情绪，讨论了蔑视、嫉妒、反感、怨恨，可能还有其他几种。对于每个环节，他都邀请了一位哲学家和一位心理学家来讨论。这就是延斯和我相遇的地方。而且，
you know, I was super excited actually when I saw the program because, you know, Yance had published this very important papers that had read. And I was really thrilled to be to be part of this event. And then, you know, an outcome of the conference was Thimo curated, curated, this special issue of the journaling which we ultimately published this, this collaboration, you know, this collaboration. And we really wanted to show how this topic has to be investigated from an interdisciplinary perspective. And even though, again, there might be some ways in which, you know, the methodologies are different to some extent. The kind of things and, you know, the explanations and the focus that I'm interested in might, you know, be different from a psychologist. There
当我看到节目单时，我其实非常兴奋，因为延斯发表过我读过的非常重要的论文。我很高兴能成为这次活动的一部分。然后，会议的一个成果是蒂莫策划了这期期刊特刊，我们最终发表了这次合作。我们真的想展示这个主题必须从跨学科的角度进行调查。尽管，再次强调，在某些方面，方法论在某种程度上是不同的。我感兴趣的事情、解释和重点可能与心理学家不同。但
is a lot of convergence. And so, again, for instance, I think philosophers who work about on on emotions and especially what are traditionally considered scenes or vices really ought to take into account the available empirical evidence. And I also think that sometimes psychologists can benefit from more nuanced conceptual distinctions. Yeah, what I found very interesting about this conference was actually the first time that I engaged with so many philosophers, to be honest. So I never met that many philosophers before. And in psychology, we always have this approach that we are kind of non-judgment So we just take a concept such as envy and then we investigate it and try to find out whether it's functional or not or when it is functional, when it is not and so on. But then all the philosophers at these conferences are giving all these talks where they were discussing whether certain emotions actually good or bad or when it is supposed to be good or bad.
有很多趋同点。所以，再次强调，我认为研究情绪，特别是那些传统上被视为罪恶或恶习的情绪的哲学家，确实应该考虑现有的实证证据。我也认为有时心理学家可以从更细致的概念区分中受益。是的，我发现这次会议非常有趣，老实说，这是我第一次与这么多哲学家接触。所以我以前从未见过这么多哲学家。在心理学中，我们总是采取一种非评判性的方法。所以我们只是拿一个像嫉妒这样的概念，然后调查它，试图找出它是否具有功能性，或者它何时具有功能性，何时不具有，等等。但会议上的所有哲学家都在做各种演讲，讨论某些情绪实际上是好是坏，或者它们应该在什么时候被认为是好是坏。
And this is where I felt we have actually complementary value, right? So we try to identify what envy leads to, what it includes, you know, what this process is and so on. And there each time you talk to someone from the media, they always want to know, is it good or can you change it? Or should we never experience envy? Or should we always experience envy? And this is something that psychologists kind of never think about. So they cannot answer it because they don't have the means to do so. But this is something where philosophers are actually extremely good at.
这就是我感到我们实际上具有互补价值的地方。我们试图确定嫉妒导致什么，它包含什么，这个过程是什么等等。每次你和媒体的人交谈，他们总是想知道，它是好的吗，或者你能改变它吗？或者我们是否应该永远不要经历嫉妒？或者我们是否应该总是经历嫉妒？这是心理学家从来不考虑的事情。所以他们无法回答，因为他们没有手段这样做。但这是哲学家实际上非常擅长的事情。
So we thought that we could join forces and show how. or envy may work from a psychological perspective and then take different philosophical perspective to find out how you should actually evaluate it. We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk about why we are so often envious of the people closest to us. New from Nespresso. Blend wellness into your coffee routine with a coffee plus range infused with functional benefits. Choose the coffee you love with added B vitamins, like coffee plus B12 to help support immune
所以我们认为我们可以联手展示嫉妒从心理学角度是如何运作的，然后采取不同的哲学视角来找出你应该如何评估它。我们要休息一下。回来后，我们将讨论为什么我们经常嫉妒最亲近的人。Nespresso 新品上市。将健康融入您的咖啡日常，推出具有功能性益处的咖啡系列。选择您喜爱的咖啡，添加维生素B，例如咖啡加B12有助于支持免疫
function and coffee plus B6 to keep your day moving. Or go with the flow and choose ginseng delight. Our new double espresso with ginseng extract. Whatever lies ahead, don't change your morning. Let your morning change you. Discover coffee plus on espresso.com. Okay. When I sell my business, I want the best tax and investment advice.
功能，咖啡加B6让您的一天充满活力。或者随心选择人参咖啡。我们全新的双份浓缩咖啡，添加了人参提取物。无论前方有什么，都不要改变您的早晨。让您的早晨改变您。在nespresso.com探索咖啡加系列。好的。当我出售我的企业时，我想要最好的税务和投资建议。
I want to help my kids and I want to give back to the community. Ooh, then it's the vacation of a lifetime. I wonder if my out of office has a forever setting. An IG Private Wealth Advisor creates the clarity you need with plans that harmonize your business, your family, and your dreams. Get financial advice that puts you at the center. Find your advisor at IDPrivatewealth.com. Well, Dr. Portasi, I want to ask you a few years ago, you published an essay about envy and frenemies, which leads me to the question, why are we often envious of people who are close?
我想帮助我的孩子，我想回馈社区。哦，那将是一生难忘的假期。我想知道我的“不在办公室”自动回复是否有永久设置。IG私人财富顾问通过协调您的业务、家庭和梦想的计划，为您创造所需的清晰度。获得以您为中心的财务建议。在IDPrivatewealth.com找到您的顾问。好吧，普罗塔西博士，我想问您几年前，您发表了一篇关于嫉妒和“友敌”的文章，这引出了我的问题，为什么我们经常嫉妒那些亲近的人，
to, whether there are friends or siblings, colleagues, even our romantic partners. I mean, why can someone else's success be so much harder to celebrate when we know that person well? So it's interesting because I've seen two reactions when I suggest that you can envy a person, a beloved, a person you love, people either react by saying, well, of course, obviously, this is an interesting to even discuss. and other people are like, what are you talking about? I would never.
无论是朋友、兄弟姐妹、同事，甚至是我们的浪漫伴侣。我的意思是，当我们非常了解那个人时，为什么别人的成功会变得如此难以庆祝？这很有趣，因为当我建议你可以嫉妒一个你爱的人时，我看到了两种反应，人们要么反应说，嗯，当然，这甚至不需要讨论。而另一些人则说，你在说什么？我永远不会。
That's impossible if you envy someone you love. You don't truly love them. And I think both things are true, right? There is in the religious tradition especially and in some philosophical approaches, envy and love are seen as complete opposites, incompatible, right? Both descriptively and normatively.
如果你嫉妒你爱的人，那是不可能的。你并没有真正爱他们。我认为这两者都是对的。在宗教传统中，特别是在一些哲学方法中，嫉妒和爱被视为完全对立、不相容的，无论是在描述上还是在规范上。
But again, that's because, one, I think there are two things happening. One is that we think of envy only in its worst manifestations, its most destructive and aggressive manifestations. And so it's true that, of course, if you are very aggressively, maliciously envious of someone, the relationship will break down. Or perhaps the love maybe in some sense was never there. But again, envy comes in different forms. And also descriptively, unfortunately, what happens is that because envy thrives in similarity, in conditions of similarity, and because we often
但同样，这是因为，第一，我认为有两件事在发生。一是我们只在嫉妒最坏的表现、最具破坏性和攻击性的表现中思考它。所以确实，如果你对某人有非常激进、恶意的嫉妒，关系就会破裂。或者也许爱在某种意义上从未存在过。但同样，嫉妒有不同的形式。而且在描述上，不幸的是，发生的情况是，因为嫉妒在相似性中滋生，在相似的条件下，而且因为我们经常
are similar in different loving relationships, the similarity is different, right? For instance, fathers and children will be similar in some obvious ways, right? Or people who are genetically related will be similar in some obvious ways. And also, you know, maybe they grew up in similar, you know, friends, childhood friends will grow up in similar environments. But even romantic partners, we know from actually scientific evidence that we, you know, similar subtracts, you know, we tend to couple with people who have similar values and similar interests. And so there is a lot of similarity. I want to be friends with people that I enjoy doing things with, people that I like,
在不同的恋爱关系中是相似的，相似性是不同的。例如，父亲和孩子在某些显而易见的方式上是相似的，或者有基因联系的人在某些显而易见的方式上是相似的。而且，也许他们是在相似的环境中长大的，童年好友会在相似的环境中长大。但即使是浪漫伴侣，我们从科学证据中也知道，我们倾向于与有相似价值观和相似兴趣的人结合。所以有很多相似之处。我想和那些我喜欢一起做事的人、我喜欢的人做朋友，
that I want to, you know, I am attracted to people in various ways. So we look for people who are attractive and we are usually connected to people who are similar to us in various ways. But then, of course, we might find out that they are. are better than us at a variety of things that perhaps we enjoy doing. So in the essay I talk about, you know, childhood friends, like high school friends, where you have this very intense relationship with someone. You do all the things together. But then comparison lurks at every corner. And so the trick there, and I talk a little bit more about some philosophical discussions of it.
我以各种方式被吸引。所以我们寻找有吸引力的人，我们通常与在各种方面与我们相似的人联系在一起。但随后，当然，我们可能会发现他们在各种我们可能喜欢做的事情上比我们更好。所以在文章中我谈到了童年好友，比如高中朋友，你和某人有非常强烈的关系。你们一起做所有的事情。但随后比较潜伏在每个角落。所以诀窍在于，我谈到了一些关于它的哲学讨论。
We don't have to go. We don't have the time to go into. But for me, the key is on the one hand, to understand that, you know, actually envy is the dark side of love and vice versa. There are two sides of the same coin. And we have to normalize the fact that, yeah, we envy people we love all the time. And it might be hard to confess and it's stigmatized, but it happens. And if we all normalize it, then, you know, we don't feel monsters and we can talk about it. For instance, with my husband, we have competed for the same jobs. When we're on the job market, we're both philosophers.
我们不必去。我们没有时间去深入探讨。但对我来说，关键一方面是要理解，实际上嫉妒是爱的阴暗面，反之亦然。它们是同一枚硬币的两面。我们必须使我们一直嫉妒我们所爱的人这一事实正常化。这可能很难承认，而且会被污名化，但它确实发生了。如果我们都使它正常化，那么我们就不会觉得自己是怪物，我们可以谈论它。例如，我和我丈夫，我们曾竞争过相同的工作。当我们在就业市场上时，我们都是哲学家，
we actually work in somewhat similar areas, there's going to be times where, you know, we envy each other. But it's okay to say, you know what, I'm feeling a little envious here. But of course, we don't want to feel the bad kind of envy. I mean, so that's where the other intervention takes place and where I think my model is helpful in understanding what are the factors that are at place. And so, you know, it's important to find oneself in a kind of growth mindset and think about, okay, how can I emulate the person?
我们实际上在有些相似的领域工作，会有时候我们嫉妒对方。但说出来没关系，你知道吗，我在这里感到有点嫉妒。但当然，我们不想感受到那种坏的嫉妒。所以这就是其他干预措施发挥作用的地方，也是我认为我的模型在理解哪些因素在起作用方面很有帮助的地方。所以，重要的是要让自己处于一种成长心态中，思考，好吧，我如何效仿那个人？
And how can I, you know, if my beloved is doing better than me in this regard, what can I learn from them? And the beloved, the other person can be generous and share, you know, their good fortune. And we can focus on how we can improve. And we can also focus on the fact that when there is a loving relationship, our identity is also somewhat shared. And so their fortune can be seen as our fortune. Although, again, I don't think that's always the case. I think it's also important to acknowledge that we are still individuals and we thrive in our own ways. I'm a little skeptical of the solution of thinking just about shared identity.
如果我所爱的人在这方面做得比我好，我能从他们那里学到什么？而所爱的人，另一个人可以慷慨地分享他们的好运。我们可以专注于我们如何改进。我们还可以专注于这样一个事实，即当存在恋爱关系时，我们的身份也在某种程度上是共享的。所以他们的好运可以被视为我们的好运。虽然，再次强调，我不认为情况总是这样。我认为承认我们仍然是独立的个体，并以自己的方式茁壮成长也很重要。我对仅仅考虑共享身份的解决方案持怀疑态度。
But so we can encourage the growth of emulative envy. And when that's not possible, we can acknowledge that ending a loved one is part of the human condition. And so we have to kind of love wisely and be able to, you know, forgive and forget when appropriate. But also simply just have frank conversations, you know, be mindful about our hostile feelings when they arise and try to kind of not shut. of them because I think a lot of relationships, my experience, personal and also otherwise, when relationships break down is often because we're not able to talk about these things in the open. Dr. Longa, I want to ask you a personality-related question, which is whether some personality
但我们可以鼓励效仿型嫉妒的成长。当这不可能时，我们可以承认嫉妒所爱之人是人类状况的一部分。所以我们必须明智地去爱，并在适当的时候能够原谅和忘记。但也仅仅是进行坦诚的对话，当敌对情绪出现时要留意它们，并尝试不要压抑它们，因为我认为很多关系，根据我的经验，个人和其他方面，当关系破裂时，往往是因为我们无法公开谈论这些事情。兰格博士，我想问您一个与人格相关的问题，即是否有些人格
types are more prone to envy than others. I mean, what might make someone particularly vulnerable to becoming envious? So as I said, people experience envy when they compare to someone else, right, in a domain of high personal relevance. So all kinds of personality traits that describe tendencies to engage in such a process will predict envy. So most obviously social comparison orientation. So if people tend to compare a lot, then they're also more likely to experience envy. Then all kinds of predictors of people, of people prefer. to deal with standards of excellence.
类型比其他人更容易嫉妒？我的意思是，什么可能使某人特别容易变得嫉妒？正如我所说，当人们在高度个人相关的领域与他人进行比较时，他们会经历嫉妒。所以所有描述参与这种过程倾向的人格特质都会预测嫉妒。最明显的是社会比较倾向。所以如果人们倾向于进行大量比较，那么他们也更有可能经历嫉妒。然后是所有关于人们偏好处理卓越标准的预测因素。
So, for instance, achievement motivation, approach and avoidance motivation, narcissism, right? So also a narcissism, people are kind of dealing standards of excellence, so they want to have an excellent self, or they want to, or short of certain standards and so on.
例如，成就动机、趋近和回避动机、自恋。所以自恋者也在处理卓越标准，他们想要拥有一个卓越的自我，或者他们想要，或者达不到某些标准等等。
And also other dark traits, such as McEvalianism, psychology, entitlement, or greed. And we also predicted by circumstances that intensify kind of personal relevance of the situation, most obviously the self-relevance of the comparison domain. So as I said, if a certain domain, it's very close to my own identity,
还有其他黑暗特质，如马基雅维利主义、心理变态、权利感或贪婪。我们也通过加剧个人相关性的情况来预测，最明显的是比较领域的自我相关性。正如我所说，如果某个领域非常接近我自己的身份，
that I'm more likely to experience envy. And when the higher-ranked person shows pride, for instance, because if it is plausible to be proud of an achievement that you have in a certain rule, then this signals that this is an important achievement to have. So this also includes the self-relevance of the domain and can make people more envious. or other kinds of signals than the person is low in status, which is something that people dislike. So being low in status, sometimes they dislike,
那么我更有可能经历嫉妒。当排名较高的人表现出骄傲时，例如，因为如果对你在某个规则中取得的成就感到自豪是合理的，那么这表明这是一个重要的成就。所以这也包括领域的自我相关性，并能使人们更嫉妒。或者其他类型的信号，即该人地位低下，这是人们不喜欢的事情。所以地位低下，有时他们不喜欢，
they don't want to be worse off because it has negative consequences for their well-being. So if these signals occur, for instance, the other person seeing that they are very prestigious or very dominant or they gain influence and this can intensify envy. And also what Sarah already mentioned, in some competitions or rivalries, there's also very high self-relevance to outperforming or real rival. So if your rival outperforms you, then this is definitely a circumstance that can intensify
他们不想处于劣势，因为它对他们的幸福有负面影响。所以如果这些信号出现，例如，对方看到他们非常有声望或非常有统治力，或者他们获得了影响力，这可能会加剧嫉妒。还有萨拉已经提到的，在一些竞争或对抗中，超越真正的对手也有很高的自我相关性。所以如果你的对手超越了你，那么这绝对是一个可以加剧
your envy. I want to ask if envy is kind of baked into us as humans, or is it something that we're taught either inadvertently or inadvertently or overtly by, say, our parents or caregivers? And is there an age when it begins to manifest itself? So my boss, Thomas Muskova, I always used to say social comparisons are ubiquitous. So it is very hard to imagine a world in which you don't compare yourself. Like let's say even if you want to say that you are a nice person, how would you actually know that you are nice? If not if you know that you are nicer than most other people, right? In a world where everyone is very nice, then you need to be much nicer than in a world in which there are not the many people who are so nice.
你嫉妒的情况。我想问嫉妒是否作为人类天生就存在于我们身上，还是它是我们被父母或照顾者无意或有意教导的东西？它开始显现的年龄是什么时候？所以我的老板，托马斯·穆斯科娃，总是说社会比较无处不在。所以很难想象一个你不进行自我比较的世界。即使你想说你是一个好人，如果你不知道你比大多数其他人更好，你实际上怎么知道你是好的？在一个每个人都很好的世界里，你需要比在一个没有那么多这么好的人的世界里更好，
So everything is kind of relative. so people always compare. But as far as I know, there is no behavior genetics research showing how much variance in this positional envy is covered for by variants in genes or so on. I mean, surely there's going to be cultural influences, right? Like anything else, you know, different cultures at different times have shaped the way we feel these social comparison emotions, right? So in our cultures, we know that like ancient Greek cultures,
所以一切都是相对的。所以人们总是比较。但据我所知，没有行为遗传学研究表明这种倾向性嫉妒中有多少变异是由基因变异等覆盖的。我的意思是，肯定会有文化影响，就像其他任何事情一样，不同文化在不同时间塑造了我们感受这些社会比较情绪的方式。所以，在我们的文化中，我们知道像古希腊文化，
or peasant cultures. I mean, there is a lot of anthropological work on envy that seems to show that, for instance, the kind of emulative envy that I talk about or even just what you call benign envy, which, you know, there is some overlap between the two. It is much harder to find examples of that in cultures where resources are very limited. There's a lot of competition just for sheer survival. And that's also why in some of those cultures, there is this superstition of the evil eye, right? where if someone looks at you or look at your children or your cattle, then misfortune happens, right?
或农民文化。关于嫉妒有很多人类学研究，似乎表明，例如，我谈到的效仿型嫉妒，或者仅仅是你所说的良性嫉妒（两者之间有一些重叠），在资源非常有限的文化中要找到这些例子要困难得多。仅仅为了生存就有很大的竞争。这也是为什么在其中一些文化中，有“邪恶之眼”的迷信，即如果有人看着你或看着你的孩子或你的牲畜，那么不幸就会发生。
There is this kind of curse, and so you have to protect yourself from envy. But that's because, again, we are in a cultural context where it's really hard to flourish and resources are limited. And so malicious envy is much more silly and in common. It's hard to find yourself in a situation where you can improve, you know, how you're doing. And so there's this cultural and just systemic structural constraints on the kind of envy that we can feel. But I also, coming back to your initial question, Kim, I do think that parents, of course, and the culture in a home will have effects on even simply, you know, whether, you know, you have a growth mindset. You think like, you know, you have an outlook on the world that is less zero sum. If you have parents who have thought to that, you know, it's either you or them, you have to succeed at all costs.
存在这种诅咒，所以你必须保护自己免受嫉妒。但这又是因为，我们处于一种很难繁荣且资源有限的文化背景中。因此，恶意的嫉妒显得更加愚蠢和普遍。你很难发现自己处于一种可以改善现状的情况下，你知道的。所以，对于我们能感受到的那种嫉妒，存在着文化和系统性的结构限制。但回到你最初的问题，Kim，我确实认为父母，当然，还有家庭文化，甚至会简单地影响你是否拥有成长型思维。你认为，你知道，你对世界的看法不是零和博弈。如果你的父母认为，你知道，要么是你，要么是他们，你必须不惜一切代价取得成功。
you have to be the first one, right? You're probably going to be more likely to feel certain kind of them, or if you feel like your parents are no supportive, they're not making you feel self-confident. Like, all of these things, I'm sure, I mean, you know, again, I don't, this is somewhat speculative, but I hope it's a reasonable speculation. And again, we just know that your context is going to affect the way you feel a variety of things, and it's going to drive some differences between people,
你必须是第一个，对吧？你可能更容易感到某种嫉妒，或者如果你觉得父母不支持你，他们没有让你感到自信。就像，所有这些事情，我敢肯定，我的意思是，你知道，再说一次，我不知道，这有点推测性，但我希望这是一个合理的推测。再说一次，我们只知道你的环境会影响你感受各种事物的方式，并且会在人与人之间产生一些差异，
think. Well, if you have parents who say, why can't you be more like your big sister or things like that? Exactly. Exactly. Things like that. I mean, that's, I do think that siblings rivalry, and there is some work on that. It is quite interesting. To some extent, I think it's pretty widespread and unavoidable for a variety of reasons that have to do with the fact that you have this very person who's similar to you and you want your parents' love and all of that. But some parents will exacerbate it and some parents might be able to alleviate it depending on how they yeah, how they do things. So definitely maybe they should not say things like that, I think. So let's talk about a little bit more practical advice. So in addition to parents not saying,
思考。嗯，如果你的父母说，为什么你就不能像你姐姐那样呢，或者类似的话？没错。没错。类似的事情。我的意思是，我确实认为兄弟姐妹之间的竞争，并且有一些关于这方面的研究。这非常有趣。在某种程度上，我认为这是相当普遍且不可避免的，原因多种多样，这与你有这样一个和你非常相似的人，而你想要父母的爱等等有关。但有些父母会加剧这种情况，而有些父母可能会根据他们做事的方式来缓解它。所以绝对地，也许他们不应该说那样的话，我想。那么让我们谈谈一些更实际的建议。所以除了父母不说，
why can't you be like your sister or your brother? I mean, if you yourself recognize that you tend to feel envious, what can you do with that emotion? How can you turn it into something that is more constructive? In my opinion, there is no general need to turn malicious envy into benign envy or to suppress your envy in general, right? Because from a psychological perspective, envy has a social function, so it helps people deal with certain social situations, in this case being worse off in a domain of high relevance to the self. And that's something that you shouldn't suppress, right?
为什么你就不能像你姐姐或哥哥那样呢？我的意思是，如果你自己意识到你倾向于感到嫉妒，你能用这种情绪做什么？你如何把它变成更具建设性的东西？在我看来，没有必要普遍地将恶意嫉妒转化为良性嫉妒，或者普遍地压抑你的嫉妒，对吧？因为从心理学的角度来看，嫉妒具有社会功能，所以它帮助人们处理某些社会情况，在这种情况下，是在对自我高度相关的领域处于劣势。这是你不应该压抑的东西，对吧？
Also, I think that benign and malicious are kind of misnomer. So benign envy can also be bad. So Sarah also always had this a nice example. I can also be benignly envious of a torturer for their torturer skills. and this would be something that's not very nice, right? Also, malicious envy can cannot be good, for instance, when it motivates you to harm dominant others who initially oppressed subordinates or so that's something that's good.
此外，我认为良性和恶意是一种用词不当。所以良性嫉妒也可能是坏的。所以Sarah也总是有这个很好的例子。我也可能对一个施虐者的施虐技巧产生良性嫉妒。这可能不是什么好事，对吧？此外，恶意嫉妒并非不能是好的，例如，当它激励你去伤害那些最初压迫下属的占主导地位的人时，或者所以那是好的事情。
So that was also part of the paper that we wrote together, that there is no easy answer here. So you shouldn't suppress envy entirely. That would be my and typically most psychologist's perspective, right? Turning malicious envy into benign envy, if you consider that to be more constructive, would kind of require that you evaluate the situation differently. So if malicious envy results because you think that the other person doesn't deserve their advantage,
所以这也是我们共同撰写的论文的一部分，这里没有简单的答案。所以你不应该完全压抑嫉妒。那将是我的观点，也是大多数心理学家的观点，对吧？如果你认为将恶意嫉妒转化为良性嫉妒更具建设性，那将需要你以不同的方式评估情况。所以，如果恶意嫉妒是因为你认为对方不配得到他们的优势而产生的，
and benign envy is more likely to occur when people think that they can actually obtain the envied good, then you need to find an intervention. It helps you to consider the object to be attainable. But I'm not aware of a strategy that actually works effectively. So we tried a few things, but it's never successfully. So maybe as Sarah knows. Well, it's more like I do think that here the philosophical and psychological perspectives diverge the most. And that's why I think when I talk about emulative envy, I agree it's not quite the same as benign envy, even though some of the research on benign envy can support some of the things I say about amulative envy. But because in my taxonomy, I do integrate that moral perspective that you find strange. Right. And so through emulative envy, especially when I talk about even like virtuous envy, which is. one version of emulative envy is when really the good that is soft after is actually good. And so in
而当人们认为他们实际上可以获得被嫉妒的物品时，良性嫉妒更有可能发生，那么你需要找到一种干预措施。它有助于你考虑该对象是可获得的。但我不知道有什么策略能真正有效地发挥作用。所以我们尝试了一些事情，但从未成功。所以也许Sarah知道。嗯，更像是，我确实认为在这里哲学和心理学的观点分歧最大。这就是为什么我认为当我谈论竞争性嫉妒时，我同意它与良性嫉妒不完全相同，尽管一些关于良性嫉妒的研究可以支持我关于竞争性嫉妒所说的一些事情。但因为在我的分类法中，我确实整合了你觉得奇怪的那种道德视角。对吧。所以通过竞争性嫉妒，特别是当我谈论甚至像美德嫉妒时，这是竞争性嫉妒的一种版本，即当所追求的善实际上是善的时候。所以
those cases, I think that's something that I think we should cultivate. And I think it is important. When I feel envy, it tells me that I care about something. And so that's the start of an introspective analysis that I think is important from a prudential and moral perspective of like, okay, am I really disadvantage in this situation? Why do I think that is that in a correct perception of the situation? And is this really good, right? Maybe I'm envious for bad reasons. And in that case, I should work on my values and then see if I become less envious. Once I realize, like, I envy someone because they have a more expensive watch, it's like,
在这些情况下，我认为这是我们应该培养的东西。我认为这很重要。当我感到嫉妒时，它告诉我我在乎某件事。所以这是内省分析的开始，我认为从审慎和道德的角度来看，这很重要，比如，好吧，我真的在这种情况下处于劣势吗？为什么我认为是这样，这是对情况的正确感知吗？这真的是好事吗，对吧？也许我因为不好的原因而嫉妒。在这种情况下，我应该努力提升我的价值观，然后看看我是否会减少嫉妒。一旦我意识到，比如，我嫉妒某人是因为他们有更昂贵的手表，就像，
maybe I should think more about whether this is actually a good thing to have or maybe, you know, I'm envious. Obviously, status drives a lot of envy. And I think I have to start from this kind of mindful self-awareness perspective of thinking, okay, what is this envy telling me? and do I want to endorse this envy? And if it is an envy that could bring me towards something productive, then again I can think about how can I work on obtaining this good?
也许我应该更多地思考这是否真的是一件好事，或者也许，你知道，我嫉妒。显然，地位驱动了大量的嫉妒。我认为我必须从这种正念的自我意识角度出发，思考，好吧，这种嫉妒在告诉我什么？我想要认可这种嫉妒吗？如果这是一种能带我走向生产性事物的嫉妒，那么我再次可以思考我如何努力获得这种善？
And if this is not achievable, maybe I can find something in the vicinity that I can pursue that is obtainable, right? And then, you know, Yance and I have some disagreement about this idea of deservingness. I think philosophers are very careful in, like, thinking that some of these cases that might be catalogued as envy are best characterized as resentment, which is a moral emotion, and so when we think about justice,
如果这是无法实现的，也许我可以在附近找到我可以追求的、可获得的东西，对吧？然后，你知道，Yance和我对这种应得性的想法有一些分歧。我认为哲学家在思考某些可能被归类为嫉妒的案例时非常谨慎，认为最好将其描述为怨恨，这是一种道德情绪，所以当我们思考正义时，
so that's a little bit of a different conversation where, for instance, you can have resentment or indignation or some sort of righteous anger at the success of people who don't deserve their success. And of course, you can also envy them on top. But I think what's doing the moral work is the moral emotion of resentment more so. But that's, I think, again, and I do think that some of the ways in which the empirical evidence seems to show that envy is driven by resentment, I do think it can also be accounted by what I call focus of concern. But anyway, that gets too technical. But I do think that this is where if someone, if a listener were interested in this kind of discussion, then I think they should look more into my book for a sense.
所以那是一个稍微不同的对话，例如，你可以对那些不配获得成功的人的成功产生怨恨或愤慨，或者某种正义的愤怒。当然，你也可以在之上嫉妒他们。但我认为起道德作用的是怨恨这种道德情绪。但我想，再说一次，我确实认为经验证据似乎表明嫉妒是由怨恨驱动的一些方式，我确实认为它也可以用我所说的关注焦点来解释。但无论如何，这太技术性了。但我确实认为，如果听众对这种讨论感兴趣，那么我认为他们应该更多地查看我的书以获得感觉。
or, you know, the work of many philosophers on these topics in thinking about how sometimes we should try to develop moral approaches to this situation and kind of separate it from our personal envy. Well, speaking of resentment makes me think of the concept of Schadenfreude, which Dr. Lange, you've studied. And I want to ask you, first of all, to explain what Chadenfreude is for some of our listeners who might know, but how does that relate? late to envy.
或者，你知道，许多哲学家在这些主题上的工作，思考我们有时应该如何尝试对这种情况发展道德方法，并将其与我们的个人嫉妒分开。嗯，说到怨恨，让我想到了幸灾乐祸的概念，Lange博士，你研究过这个。我想首先请你为我们一些可能知道的听众解释什么是幸灾乐祸，但这与嫉妒有什么关系。
So what is Shaden, it's when people laugh about other people's failure. Let's say someone experiences a misstep and you are laughing at what happened to them. Then this would be Shaden, Florida. So Shaden is harm, a German word for harm, and Freud is joy, so enjoying others, pain, kind of.
那么什么是幸灾乐祸，就是当人们嘲笑别人的失败时。假设某人经历了一次失误，而你在嘲笑发生的事情。那么这就是幸灾乐祸。所以Shaden是伤害，一个德语词，意思是伤害，而Freud是快乐，所以享受别人的痛苦，某种程度上。
So there is evidence or meta-analytic evidence, overwhelming evidence, I would say, that Shaden-Froid is actually predicted by malicious. envy. So if you think that someone else's advantage is subjectively underserved, that's a psychological idea of it. So it's not from an objective moral standpoint. But I think, I don't want this person to be so successful, right? Then then this is more likely to lead to malicious envy. And if you then subsequently see this person fail on another occasion, then laughing publicly about this person actually reduces this other person standing in the
所以有证据或元分析证据，压倒性的证据，我会说，幸灾乐祸实际上是由恶意嫉妒预测的。所以如果你认为别人的优势在主观上是不应得的，那是一个心理学概念。所以它不是从客观的道德立场出发的。但我认为，我不希望这个人如此成功，对吧？那么这更有可能导致恶意嫉妒。如果你随后在另一个场合看到这个人失败，那么公开嘲笑这个人实际上会降低这个人在
group. Right. So if everyone is laughing. I'm laughing about this person and no one else disagrees, then this person can't be so cool. So this is one way how malicious and we can help reduce the problem. So the other person is no longer a social comparison standard of high standing. This person has been laughed at by me and ideally other people. So this process is most likely for what we call dominant others. So people who initially gained influence in a group by oppressive. subordinates.
群体中的地位。对吧。所以如果每个人都在笑。我在嘲笑这个人，而没有其他人反对，那么这个人就不可能那么酷。所以这是恶意嫉妒可以帮助减少问题的一种方式。所以另一个人不再是高地位的社会比较标准。这个人被我和理想情况下其他人嘲笑了。所以这个过程对于我们所说的占主导地位的人来说最有可能。所以那些最初通过压迫下属而在群体中获得影响力的人。
So dominant others are more likely to be maliciously envied for their standing in the group. And then publicly laughing about them reduces the fear everyone has towards them. So we actually argued that Chardon for this social function is to reduce the standing of the dominant people. So yeah, from a functional perspective, and whether that's good or bad, that's a philosopher's question to answer. Well, let me just close with one question, which has to do with. social media and whether that is leading us to feel more envious.
所以占主导地位的人更有可能因为他们在群体中的地位而受到恶意嫉妒。然后公开嘲笑他们会减少每个人对他们的恐惧。所以我们实际上争辩说，幸灾乐祸的这种社会功能是降低占主导地位的人的地位。所以是的，从功能角度来看，这到底是好是坏，那是哲学家要回答的问题。嗯，让我用一个问题来结束，这与社交媒体有关，以及它是否导致我们感到更嫉妒。
Does seeing other people's carefully curated lives online create some very distorted form of social comparison for us? Is it making us more envious? So, I mean, there is evidence that social media can foster upward social comparisons, right? And there's also evidence that being on social media can increase people. people's envy, so there's longitudinal evidence. If you are more on social media,
看到别人在网上精心策划的生活是否为我们创造了一种非常扭曲的社会比较形式？它是否让我们更嫉妒了？所以，我的意思是，有证据表明社交媒体可以促进向上的社会比较，对吧？而且还有证据表明使用社交媒体可以增加人们的嫉妒，所以有纵向证据。如果你更多地使用社交媒体，
then you're more likely to experience state envy and not the other way around, so envy is not predicting your social media news. But it is important to emphasize that this applies primarily to a specific form of using social media. So if you are passively browsing to other success stories, so let's say Sarah is again sharing news
那么你更有可能体验到状态嫉妒，而不是相反，所以嫉妒并不能预测你的社交媒体使用。但重要的是要强调，这主要适用于使用社交媒体的特定形式。所以如果你是被动地浏览其他成功故事，所以假设Sarah再次分享新闻
about her latest book or an amazing envy paper on whatever social media, let's say on Instagram, you know, then and I'm browsing through my content and I see this and this can lead to a social comparison and subsequently envy. But if people, for instance, passively browse through news content or like actively engaged in social media by posting something on Instagram themselves,
关于她的最新书或任何社交媒体上令人惊叹的嫉妒论文，假设在Instagram上，你知道，那么我正在浏览我的内容并看到了这一点，这可能导致社会比较，随后产生嫉妒。但如果人们，例如，被动地浏览新闻内容，或者像通过自己在Instagram上发布一些东西来积极参与社交媒体，
that this is not making people envy it. And also this relationship between passive use in a highly self-relevant domain, whether this leads to more envy also depends on personality characteristics. For instance, a review found that social comparison orientation is a personality predictor of this relationship, which means that only for people who tend to compare a lot, passively browsing to other people's success stories on social media actually leads to more envy. So as usual, the evidence is mixed and very nuanced.
这并不会让人嫉妒。而且，这种在高度自我相关领域中的被动使用与这是否会导致更多嫉妒之间的关系也取决于人格特征。例如，一项综述发现，社会比较取向是这种关系的人格预测因子，这意味着只有对于那些倾向于进行大量比较的人来说，被动浏览社交媒体上别人的成功故事实际上会导致更多的嫉妒。所以像往常一样，证据是混合的且非常微妙。
So claiming that these few more state envy experiences then produce kind of a just, general rights in this position of envy, I think this conclusion is not warranted. So at least there is no direct evidence for this. So my personal impression is that social media is just one specific context in which envy can occur, but another that it kind of increases people's propensity to be more envious in general. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. I think this has been very interesting, and I really loved having the two perspectives, philosophical and psychological. Thank you so much. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org
所以声称这些更多的状态嫉妒体验随后产生了一种普遍的、一般的嫉妒倾向，我认为这个结论是不合理的。所以至少没有直接证据支持这一点。所以我个人的印象是，社交媒体只是嫉妒可能发生的一种特定环境，而不是它增加了人们普遍更嫉妒的倾向。嗯，我要感谢你们两位今天加入我。我认为这非常有趣，我真的很喜欢这两种观点，哲学和心理学。非常感谢。谢谢。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上找到之前关于心理学的剧集
or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的剧集有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。Speaking of Psychology由Lee Weinerman制作。感谢收听。美国心理学会。我是Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。